-Today's Friday and that's
usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff,
you know, I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was just running
a bit behind today,
so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now.
Is that cool?
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
-[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's my man.
-Christmas spirit came early.
-Yeah, Christmas spirit,
the Ghost of Christmas Present
right here.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, Taylor Swift,
for giving us all more "Red."
And thank you, People magazine,
for giving us all
more Rudd.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, yeah!
-That's my dude!
-Come on.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
"Red (Taylor's Version),"
[ Cheering and applause ]
for being the music
world's version
of labeling your food
in the office fridge.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's like, "That's mine."
"That's its says,
'Todd's rice pudding.'"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Ugh!"
-"Agh!
You don't even
understand my life."
[ Laughter ]
-"I sit at home,
make rice pudding,
I bring it in
and you animals eat it!"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Thank you, "Dexter: New Blood,"
for premiering
on Showtime this week.
Or, as "Squid Game" put it,
"Oh, you murder
one person each episode?
That's cu-u-u-te."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Thanksgiving,
for being the one day
in November
we don't spend preparing
for Christmas.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I can't wait for Christmas.
-I don't care what anybody says.
I like Christmas.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
♪♪
Thank you, crossword puzzles,
for being
the most frustrating way
to remind myself
that I'm an idiot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't know any
of these things.
"Blank Fallon,
host of 'The Tonight Show.'"
-"I have no idea."
[ Laughter ]
-It's you, you dummy!
-Oh, ma'am!
[ Laughter ]
It's your name, dummy!
My mom and dad, when we
first got "The Tonight Show,"
they watched
some local news show
and they had a trivia
question thing about me
and they were answering the TV.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like "His first --"
and they're like,
"Saugerties High School!"
[ Laughter ]
It's like,
"This isn't for you, this game."
[ Aww and laughter ]
But, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway.
Never mind.
-Yeah.
Well, no, wait, what?
-Agh! [ Laughs ]
-No.
No, what is it? What is it?
-I'm good.
It's just --
Moving on. Never mind.
-You seem upset.
-No, I'm fine.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, come on.
Don't be that way.
What is it?
-No, no, have a good time.
The party's fun, man.
Thanks for having me.
I'm going to take you with me.
We're having a party.
No, no, no. You can stay.
What's the matter?
-Well, I just haven't
talked to my dad.
-What about?
-Fifteen years.
[ Suspenseful-melancholy
tune plays ]
It all happened
because it was Christmas Eve.
-Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
What happened?
-I didn't tell you?
-No.
-This is insane.
My grandma...
-Right.
I know.
I love your grandma.
I just saw her --
-Boy, my dad loved
his own mother, sure.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-We we're drinking, you know.
-Sure.
Christmas --
-Christmas Eve, sure.
She had -- She had this wig on
and everything,
that matched the candles.
It was blue and silver.
It was funny.
We were just having fun
and I guess she forgot
to take her pills or something.
-Right.
♪♪
Can we turn the cameras off?
[ Jingling bells join music ]
[ Laughter ]
She, uh...
♪♪
...staggers out of the house.
-Right.
Drunk as a skunk, which is fine.
-Crazy-drunk,
embarrassingly drunk, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh,
we didn't hear from her
the next day.
[ Laughter ]
She disappeared?
What --
-I found her.
-Where?
-Right in front of the house.
[ Laughter ]
Grandma had been run over
by a reindeer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
♪♪
Where?
-Walking home, from our house.
-On Christmas Eve?
[ Laughter ]
-There were hoof--
Her bare back was exposed.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Somehow, her dress
had been ripped off.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
-There were hoove marks --
-Hoove marks on her back?
-Hoove marks on her back.
-Oh, my God!
What kind of animals did this?
Reindeer, apparently.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-You can say
you don't believe in Santa.
-Right, but your grandpa,
I know he's a man of faith.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Man of faith, yeah.
We still believe in Santa, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway. [ Clears throat ]
Can't believe I didn't
tell you that.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Playing tender tune ]
-Thank you, cider doughnuts,
for being regular doughnuts
that are like,
"Um, we're not like
other doughnuts."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, goatees,
for being the sweater vest
of beards.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my "Thank You Notes."